first good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight last may a 17 year old
high school senior called payton gendron
received an assignment in his economics
class the assignment asked what do you
want to do when you retire he answered
commit murder-suicide
teacher immediately reported his threat
to authorities who sent him to the
emergency room for a psychiatric
evaluation
gendron was there for just 20 hours as
he wrote later in his diary quote i got
out of it because i stuck with the story
that i was getting out of class and i
just stupidly wrote that down that's the
reason i believe i am still able to
purchase guns
but he was lying
gendron's intention to commit mass
murder was as he later wrote quote not a
joke i wrote that down because that's
what i was planning to do
and he was
peyton gendron was mentally ill his
classmates knew that gendron made
strange facial expressions and said odd
things in class
last year he showed up for school for a
full week wearing a hazmat suit boots
gloves everything recalled another
student
police and school administrators
understood perfectly well that gendron
was potentially dangerous that's why
they sent him to the psych ward even his
own parents must have known that
something was very wrong gendron's diary
describes how his mother helped him bury
a cat he had beaten to death in their
garage and then beheaded with a hatchet
on saturday peyton gendron as you know
finally did what he said he would do he
committed mass murder he opened fire on
a crowd of strangers in a buffalo
supermarket he murdered 10 of them
so how did the adults around him let
this happen in a country with
functioning leadership we would be
asking that question the signs of mental
illness were certainly there the people
in charge missed those signs or didn't
take them seriously enough weren't
paying close enough attention in any
case they didn't fix it they let it kill
or slip through
so what did they do wrong with peyton
gendron and how can we learn from it we
should learn from it if we want to
prevent more mass murders
but that's not all what our leaders are
asking tonight hardly instead they're
asking the only question that ever
occurs to them how exactly can i benefit
from this how can i leverage this
tragedy to my advantage how can other
people's suffering make me more powerful
it didn't take long for joe biden to
find a way biden flew to buffalo this
morning to speak about what payton
gendron did
there have been a number of mass murders
since biden became president some of
them have been racially motivated a
little over a year ago in fact there was
even another supermarket massacre that
happened to have the same casualty total
a syrian born man murdered 10 people in
boulder colorado even used the same
caliber rifle that patron gendron
brought to buffalo
but joe biden didn't bother to fly to
that crime scene he didn't go to any of
them in fact biden went to buffalo today
because he thought he could blame his
political opponents for what happened
there which of course he promptly did
watch and other nations ask me heads of
state in other countries
ask me
what's going on
what in god's name happened on january 6
what happened in buffalo what happened
to ask
january 6th and the buffalo massacre
so how is a political protest at the
capitol related to a murder spree by a
demented teenager in new york state over
the weekend what do those two events
have in common and who exactly are these
unnamed heads of state who are
connecting these non-connected events in
conversations with joe biden
you may have wondered that but don't ask
because it's not meant to be asked it
isn't said a dream sequence it's a
rhetorical device meant to connect
everything that might challenge joe
biden and bunch all these things
together in the same repulsive moral
category
january 6 mass murder the bubonic plague
it's all the same it's all bad
and because it's bad joe biden informed
us today after 250 years we're going to
have to suspend the bill of rights and
we're going to begin
where the bill of rights begins with the
freedom of speech
you can't prevent people from being
radicalized to violence
but we can't address the relentless
exploitation of the internet to recruit
and mobilize terrorism
the relentless exploitation of the
internet to recruit and mobilize
terrorism
okay but can anyone show has anyone ever
shown that this specific
case peyton gendron was quote recruited
and mobilized by the internet well no in
fact by his own account
he was mentally ill he snapped he'd been
planning this for a long time he did
what his diseased brain commanded him to
do the internet did not make him do it
he did it himself
but even if gendron had been quote
radicalized by what he read on the
internet
what then exactly
many have been radicalized by what
they've read paul pott was radicalized
by reading dos capitel he went on a
murder spree he killed more than a
million people should we ban that book
should we ban all books all internet
sites that quote radicalize people what
exactly is joe biden saying here
well he's saying that thanks to what
happened in buffalo over the weekend you
no longer have any rights at all
including the most basic which is to
read what you want
after nullifying the first amendment joe
biden moved to the second amendment
the venom of the haters
and their weapons of war
the violence and the words and deeds the
the
that stalk our streets our stores our
schools this venom this violence cannot
be the story of our time
but there are certain things we can do
we can keep assault weapons off our
streets
we've done it before
so because a mentally ill 18 year old
used a specific rifle to commit these
crimes you can't have that rifle now joe
biden's bodyguards can have that rifle
so can nancy pelosi's and of course they
do in fact you pay for it all but
they're important and you are not so you
can't
so because the people in charge fail to
protect shoppers in buffalo you're not
allowed to defend your family despite
the fact you may believe your family's
every bit as important as joe biden and
his family and nancy pelosi and her
family
but they're not as important
so we're going to defund the police and
disarm you that's how it works now sorry
and then joe biden got to the main point
of his speech which is that people who
criticize his immigration policies are
responsible for the violence you saw in
buffalo here's the president of the
united states explaining that
a hate
that through the media
and politics the internet
has radicalized angry alienated lost and
isolated individuals into falsely
believing
that they will be replaced that's the
word replaced
by the other
and i condemn those
who spread the lie for power
political gain
and for profit
so you lock the country down
lock kids out of their schools
for two years force them to get quote
educated on the internet but it's
someone else's fault that they're quote
alienated
they've been hearing about the great
replacement theory
you've heard a lot about the great
replacement theory recently it's
everywhere in the last two days and
we're still not sure exactly what it is
here's what we do know for a fact there
is a strong political component to the
democratic party's immigration policy
we're not guessing this we know this and
we know it because they have said so
they've said it again and again and
again they've written books on it and
monographs and magazine articles they've
bragged about it endlessly they talk
about it on cable news constantly and
they say out loud we are doing this
because it helps us to win elections
that's not something is said once it's
something they've gloated about again
and again and again and we think that's
wrong and in case you doubt us here they
are
blue wave is african-american
[Applause]
it's white it's latino it's asia pacific
islander it is made up of those who've
been told that they are not worthy of
being here
it is comprised of those who are
documented and undocumented in a couple
of presidential cycles you'll be on
election night you'll be announcing that
we're calling the 38 electoral votes of
texas for the democratic nominee for
president it's changing it's going to
become a purple state and then a blue
state because of the demographics the
demographics of america are not on the
side of the republican party the new
voters in this country are moving away
from them
instead they're moving to be
independents or even vote on the other
side an unrelenting stream of
immigration
nonstop
non-stop
folks like me who were
caucasian of european descent
for the first time in 2017 will be an
absolute minority in the united states
of america
minority
fewer than 50 percent of the people in
america from then and on
will be
white european stock
that's not a bad thing that's that's a
source of our strength
so you play clips of them saying it and
you're the deranged conspiracy tonight
maybe the funniest part is they may not
be right the democratic party has
decided then rather than convince you
people who are born here that their
policies are helping you and making the
country better and stronger they will
change the electorate again they say
that we're not guessing
but the funniest part is they may be
wrong actually judging by recent polling
it turns out your average salvadoran
landscaper is politics are a lot closer
to donald trump's than they are to joe
biden and nancy pelosi so their basic
calculation may be completely wrong but
that's not even the point it has nothing
to do with who we're letting in there's
something with race and ethnicity it has
to do with two things one the purpose of
the us government is to serve american
citizens period and two you should never
craft any federal which is to say
nationwide policy in order to help a
specific political party that is by
itself in isolation immoral it doesn't
matter what the policy is
and that's exactly what they're doing
and again they brag about it and not
just democratic party politicians
virtually every media figure on the left
has been bragging about this for decades
oh it's a conspiracy theory really well
here's anna navarro from her time as a
harvard fellow this is what she wrote
quote the demographic trends show that
the minority vote in the united states
will continue to grow in numbers and
influence unless you're under the
influence of hallucinogens it is hard to
imagine future scenarios the republican
party can win national elections that
piece by the way is called old white
straight male voters ain't what they
used to be end quote
so let's see if you don't want people to
be paranoid and angry maybe you don't
write pieces like that and rub it right
in their face and give them the finger
day after day maybe that would
de-escalate it a little bit you think
joe biden anna navarro
but they're not the only two this has
been the prevailing view on the left for
a long time here's a political piece
from 2013 we could go on for hours by
the way but here's this quote
immigration reform could be a bonanza
for democrats the democratic party that
piece said are quote pumping as many as
11 million new hispanic voters into the
electorate a decade from now in ways
that could produce an electoral bonanza
for democrats and [ __ ] republican
prospects in many states they now win
easily end quote again as noted that
calculation may be completely wrong a
lot of those people the democrats are
importing may wind up being deeply
sympathetic to the other party because
they're actually not white liberals
that's the secret
but it almost doesn't matter how they
vote thinking about politics in those
terms is immoral that is wrong you are
gaming the system that is not democracy
it's the opposite and they bragged about
it for more than a decade here's another
example also from 2013 the center for
american progress announced that quote
supporting real immigration reform that
contains a pathway to citizenship for
our nation's 11 million undocumented
immigrants is the only way to maintain
electoral strength in the future oh
grace replace great replacement theory
anyone
these people are lunatics
they're telling you what their strategy
is when you note it they scream at you
and call you a criminal in 2018 the new
york times published an editorial called
we can replace them
just in case subtlety is not your thing
quote
right now america is tearing itself
apart as an embittered white
conservative minority clings to power
terrified of being swamped by a new
multi-racial polyglot majority
right okay in 2020 joe scarborough real
moral voice over at msnbc quoted this
trumpism accelerated damage done by
demographic changes and will harm
republicans for years demographics is
destiny end quote are you allowed to say
that once again they're wrong
and if you haven't looked at an attorney
electoral map recently look at the
districts the almost 100 hispanic
districts in the rio grande valley that
are bearing the brunt of our open
borders
they're now red so you're wrong joe
scarborough but the fact that you're
saying demographics is destiny tells you
the great replacement theory is coming
from the left they don't think it's a
theory they think it's real in 2021 the
washington post jen rubin celebrated a
report that the number of white people
in this country was declining can you
even imagine quote this is fabulous news
she wrote now we need to prevent
minority white rule
my god talking like that is there any
more divisive thing you could write we
could give you a million more examples
we're offended by this because it's
wrong and we've said so but for saying
so according to carl cameron on msnbc
today we should be thrown in jail watch
you gotta watch out because the
republicans have become the purveyors of
misinformation
and when our two-party system is broken
like that
democracy is seriously in trouble the
president acknowledged that it's time to
actually start doing things and maybe
taking some names and putting people in
jail
maybe taking some names and putting
people in jail hmm who would those
people be well thanks to the senate
majority leader chuck schumer of new
york we now know schumer to send a
letter to our bosses here at fox news
blaming this show for the mass murder in
buffalo as well as several other mass
shootings in recent years according to
chuck schumer this show spreads quote
dangerous rhetoric it needs to be pulled
off the air immediately in the name of
public safety
now again chuck schumer is a federal
official he is the leading democrat in
the united states senate
and he is calling for media censorship
now there was a time like maybe 18
months ago and that would be considered
a direct violation the first amendment
now we hear it every day let's throw
them in jail
we wanted to hear more from chuck
schumer about this we invited him on the
show tonight as we always do
because he is a coward this is the only
immediate appearance probably in history
he's turned down
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight